[Music]
we're going to begin this hour of course
with queen elizabeth you just saw her a
minute ago greeting the people on the
opening day of her platinum jubilee this
is what they call the money shot
everybody's been waiting to see when is
she coming out who is she coming out
with
who will be on the balcony who will not
be on the balcony the queen had said
earlier that she wanted to include just
the uh working members of the royal
family so that's why you see
prince charles and his wife camilla yeah
let's just listen the crowd oh we just
cut to a shot of the of a flight flyover
crowd was welcoming her cheers claps
hoots and hollers of course
because oh look at little louie because
she is so beloved
and there's his mother
catherine's i don't know what she's
saying to louie just
look up in the skies darling because
they have a big fly over it's all a
tribute to the queen and look at the
queen
she's very engaged in this moment you
know there was some question as to how
much of the how much would she be able
to
participate in the ceremonies and is
there on the on the balcony that's nice
this traditional displays the following
of the this traditional display always
follows the annual military parade in
london it's called the trooping the
color but this time it has a little
extra meaning because it's part of the
celebration of the queen's 70-year reign
holly williams is there she's along the
parade route holly good morning to you
you've got a great seat i wish i was
there for this good morning to you
that's right i can hear the plane
screaming overhead gail when the queen
just appeared on the balcony of
buckingham palace for the second time
this morning a few moments ago she was
met with a giant cheer by the thousands
of people who've gathered here to
celebrate her 70 years on the throne
she's dressed in in light blue or
lavender it's difficult to tell which we
know that she loves bright colors and
she is carrying a walking stick we know
that she's had mobility issues in recent
months she's been joined on that balcony
by other members of the royal family for
this military fly pass that you can hear
overhead including prince charles head
of the throne his son prince william his
wife kate and their children prince
george princess charlotte and prince
louis we've already seen those three
children earlier today riding in an open
top carriage also met with massive
cheers the mood here is jubilant this
platinum jubilee is really being seen in
this country as a giant thank you by the
nation to the queen who remains
massively popular at the age of 96.
other events this weekend include a pop
concert here at buckingham palace on
saturday night headlined by diana ross
and queen with adam lambert now prince
harry and his wife megan are also here
for the celebrations and it will be her
first public appearance in the uk since
they moved to the u.s we understand that
the queen will be holding a lunch for
members of the royal family later on
today and we assume that harry and megan
will be there dale
but we hear the flyover i assume they're
going to be there too i know prince
william is on the balcony too right
holly we just can't see him in the shot
but isn't prince william there
i i believe he is i'm yeah
just a little bit yeah
i believe he's there gayle and we saw
him earlier on
we saw him earlier of course on
horseback taking part in in the review
of the troops alongside his father
all
prince
ali stay with us just a minute because
we want to chat with you some more about
this celebration let's bring in mark
phillips who's also covering the
platinum jubilee mark now we talked
about this birthday parade trooping the
color and kicking off this platinum
jubilee but once again explain the
significance of this moment
well the significance is a very simple
one it's never happened before no
monarch has ever reigned this long in
more than a thousand years of british
royal history involving you know the
windsors and the various dynasties that
that preceded them the closest would
have been victoria she's been surpassed
there's going to be noise in a second
there we go
and the
the amusingly in a way the this
surpasses all royal records here
but in terms of the overall world world
record that's still held by louis the
14th of france it's got two years to go
to hit that hit that and i bet you can
get a pretty good bet of the bookies
that she will
now we we see the queen on the balcony
um she won't be watching the troops
reviewing the troops in person but her
grandchildren her children will be
standing in her place what does that
mean
well this what we're
what we're looking at here is what
they're called the trim down royals the
working royals obviously missing is
prince andrew who's been disgraced
because of his association with jeffrey
epstein obviously missing are harry and
megan because of their decision not to
be working royals anymore getting the
fly pass now that you see of the red
arrows which is the royal air force
ceremonial flight
streaming appropriately in red white and
blue and that will be the the end of
this flypass for me i don't know if you
saw it the best part of it is the world
war ii flight the old lancasters and
spitfires and hurricanes but leave that
aside for a minute what you're seeing on
the balcony is this kind of working
royal and what we're witnessing is a
process of a gradual trimming down
for reasons having to do with family but
also for reasons for having to do with
the role of the royals in this country a
process that will continue whenever that
happens knock on wood under under the
next uh monarch who of course will be
prince charles but um with the anthem's
now going this has been a pretty rousing
start
i think so too i'm so glad it did not
rain on the queen's parade holly let's
go back to you because you're on the
parade route with you've been talking to
the people all morning i'm so fascinated
by the numbers that have turned out the
way they've camped out for several days
they just wanted to be a part of this
explain why the queen is so beloved in
that country
oh it's such a good question you know
people here are really excited it's a
big show of patriotism a lot of people
flying the union jack which we don't you
know see that much of in this country i
think it's so interesting when you think
about the change that she's been through
when she ascended the throne this
country was still mired in post-war uh
poverty it was an overwhelmingly white
country
and it was still very much defined by
the class system fast forward 70 years
this is a country that's embraced uh
multiculturalism it's a country it's
very much a modern society and the class
system doesn't define people in the same
way that it does and yet she who hasn't
changed very much is still
overwhelmingly popular
loved by her people and seen as relevant
holly we see some movement in the crowd
behind you uh before i ask you what that
movement might be i just have to point
out that the uh
little uh prince george uh will and
kate's youngest uh child uh i think
stole the show on that balcony i know
it's the queen's jubilee but he was
there uh yeah that's louis louie's the
youngest one louie's the youngest one
yeah louie is the youngest one george
it's george charlotte and then louis oh
that was boring
middle child little little little louie
yeah
uh very sweet they're covering his ears
and the jets are flying over and
pointing a little bit and then you know
it's only a five-minute ceremony but
he's already getting tired
how much longer is this going to go on
yeah very very very sweet but that you
know holly that's part of what i think
the if i understand it correctly the
british public is interested in the
whole family dynamic all the
personalities all the quirks uh that's
it i mean it's it's about them as a true
family but i do see the movement behind
you in the crowd what's next on the
schedule today
i think people are moving down towards a
buckingham palace as i understand it
what's next on this schedule is this
family lunch that will be inside
buckingham palace for members of the
royal family and then later on today
there's going to be a lighting of
beacons uh around this country very sort
of symbolic event um and that will be
led by prince william here at buckingham
palace and the queen at one of her other
residences windsor castle
all right ollie williams and mark
phillips for us in london thank you to
you both we'll check in later